foreign
advances in all aspects of Our Lives
programming has become increasingly
important it is used in many fields and
industries including software
development gaming and entertainment
education scientific research web
development and many more so needless to
say the demand for programming and
coding in the IT industry will probably
keep increasing for the foreseeable
future but where does chart Deputy open
ai's popular language model fall in this
chain that's exactly what we are
focusing on in this today's video on
that note welcome to the simply learn
YouTube channel today we are here with
an interesting video on chat DPT for
programming scientificity is after all a
product of artificial intelligence if
you want to know more about artificial
intelligence and become an expert in the
field of AI consider the artificial
intelligence engineer master program by
simply learn and master those necessary
skills check out the link in the
description for more details as I said
earlier programming is utilized in many
domains like web development robotics
mobile development machine learning and
so on so how can a program achieve
maximum code efficiency nowadays we have
EI based tools like chargeupt to make
our programming experience more
efficient although there are several
coding resources platforms such as stack
Overflow and GitHub where programmers
can find solutions to their technical
programming questions charging stands
out from the competition because of its
quick response time usability and
support for numerous languages among
many other benefits now let's first
discuss how chatgpt Works charging
generates responses to the text input
using a method called Transformer
architecture a large volume of text is
fed into the chat GPT from various
sources including books website and
other social media platforms the model
then uses this information to forecast
the following word in a phrase based on
the words that came before it the charge
ability systems allows users to enter
text or queries and then the system uses
its training data and algorithms to
produce the right answer the answer is
created after the input text has been
examined and the pattern most likely to
match the input have been identified
using the training data in short charge
APD is designed to respond to queries
logically and command more quickly and
accurately but why do programmers use
chargeability on a regular basis charge
Deputy assist programmers by offering
programming related answers and
solutions and helping them improve their
skills besides that charge Deputy is
utilized for code generation code
completion code review and a natural
language interface let us understand
each in detail charge is trained to
generate the code or even the entire
program described in the natural
language specified by what they want a
program to do and then charge video
could generate the relevant code look at
the example of how chargpt generates the
code so now open the charge GPT and you
can type any program that you want rgbt
to generate so I will give write a
parallel program in Java so here you can
type write a
palindrome
program in Java
so using Java programming language it
should generate the whole program
so as you can see it has generated the
program so it has used a class name
called palindrome Checker and it has
used each palindrome as a method name
and also it will give the explanation on
the program so you can see here why it
is explaining why each palindrome is
used as a method and it also explains
the for Loop if
a condition and so on next we have code
completion charging is trained to
generate Snippets of code or even fully
fledged programs it can generate a list
of possible code completion depending on
the context of the user's incomplete
piece of Code by automatically producing
the entire code it can help the
developers save time and minimize errors
next let's see the example of code
completion using tatibility so even if
the program is explained in natural
language chargpt will generate the
proper code and give the complete code
so let's type here
using a function
write a program
to convert
the string
in uppercase
so using which language let's keep using
C programming
and enter it once again
so as you can see we have just said that
using a function write a program to
convert the string in uppercase so using
C programming language and using C
programming language it has used
function and you know this is the
function convert to uppercase and has
come given the complete code for string
to convert a string in uppercase and
also it gave the explanation here the
convert to uppercase function takes a
pointer to a string as its argument and
then iterates over each character in the
string using a for Loop so it explained
why for Loop is used why two upper is
used and why the method convert to
uppercase is used everything
so let's say we'll give one piece of
code like void
to Upper
care
Str
so as you can see we just gave the
method to Upper and it's generating the
complete code
so this is how chargedipity works for
code completion next code review
chargingly can analyze code identify the
bugs or errors in the program and
further help resolve them it allows
developers to fix errors more quickly so
now let's have a look at the example of
code review so in this example chat
Deputy will review the code so even if
the code has some mistake it will give
the proper output let's say we have
given the example here
so we gave
the function or a method called upper
and here we are giving
the keyword called upward so you should
check whether this piece of code is
proper or is there any mistake in this
so as I said
uh it's saying that the given code
appears to have logical error as a
function upper is being called
recursively on itself inside the loop
so instead of giving two upper we just
gave upper here right so using the
keyword to Upper only then this string
can be converted to uppercase so here we
gave just upper so it says that it is
having this piece of code is having a
logical error and it gives the proper
code for us
so I hope it's clear
and then we have natural language
interface with the use of chargept a
software application can be given a
natural language user interface that
enables users to communicate with it
through natural language instructions
rather than through conventional user
interfaces next let's see how chargity
helps the programmers for natural
language interface so let's say we'll
give here
create
a software application
where
the user
asked to enter
credential
for the to-do app
enter
so as you can see
the charge video will give the steps so
it can provide you with an outlet for
creating a software applications that
requires the user to enter credential
for a to-do app so here it is few steps
that we need to follow to do a to-do app
so it's giving the explanation step by
step
so it says that determine the
programming language and framework then
set up the database to store the user
information and then create the
registration page and then finally
create the login page as well and once
the user is successfully logged in
um you know it will have the options
like add edit and delete task as well
and then finally implement the security
measures to you know protect your
passwords and then test the application
to ensure that it works as intended and
the user data is being stored and
retrieved correctly so it gives the
steps of how it has to be developed so
guys what are your thoughts on how
effective the charge Deputy is for
programming do let us know in the
comment section please like this video
and share it with your friends for any
queries regarding this topic mention
them in the comment box thank you
like this video subscribe to the simply
learn YouTube channel and click here to
watch similar videos turn it up and get
certified click here
foreign